quel sera l'impact de l'arrivée de cette
crise des migrants sur y ait dans la
joute électorale
on va en discuter avec notre panel
mais cette affaire illustre surtout
comment un événement relativement est
prévue peut prendre d'assaut la scène
politique est chamboulé toutes les
stratégies minutieusement planifié
d'avancé
comment donc gérer une crise en pleine
campagne j'en discute avec nos stratèges
robert asselin est conseillé de justin
trudeau
car bélanger conseiller principal de
thomas mulcair et catherine loubier
conseillère de sites est venu un peu
pour le québec les porte parole de la
campagne
ramuz catherine je vais commencer avec
vous on une campagne on est toutes
organisées on se lève le matin et on
voit une photo cette semaine cette photo
de cet enfant le lien avec le canada
qu'est ce qui arrive évidemment quand on
a une crise comme ça on prend le pouls à
savoir est-ce qu'on peut procéder avec
notre annonce est ce qu'on peut
peut-être si c'est un événement tragique
en parlait au début d'une conférence de
presse où garder ça pour la période des
questions
effectivement dans ce cas si c'était
tellement une crise mondiale avec un
autre canadien que nous on a choisi
d'annuler finalement l' annonce du jour
et on s'est concentré sur ça ah les
autres parties ont décidé de procéder
avec leurs annonces pourquoi justement
parce qu'il ya tout un calcul maintenant
et on veut pas faire de partisanerie
mais tout est planifié vous vous aviez
une annonce sur le pont champlain cette
journée là c'est quand même un fait
important dans votre campagne vous citez
sur le sur les retraites qualité le
calcul yahia vosges est important c'est
que à comprendre c'est que la logistique
d'une campagne c'est très serré à chaque
journée planifie d'avant ça l'air de
dire on va mais par exemple non sur le
pont champlain quand on sait que le chef
est à montréal
une journée qui va revenir dans 20 jours
dans dix jours nous ont décidé de
procéder mais on trouve important que le
chef le chef adresse la question fasse
une déclaration sur ce sujet là c'est ce
qui a fait de toute façon le matin quand
on se lève on voit l'emploi de ça on
sait que peu importe ce qu'on va dire ce
qu'on va annoncer c'est ça qui va
dessiner la journée car vous parce que
vous vous votre chef au fait son annonce
il ya attendu lui qu'on pose des
questions c'est quoi le calcul derrière
ce calcul était qu'on ne l'ait pas avoir
l'air de profiter d'une crise majeure
qui était tragique et de faire la
politique là dessus alors ce qu'on a
décidé eux aussi de ce procédé avec
notre annonce les tout était prêt à
aller de l'avant
ils ont attendu que la question viennent
les journalistes pour avant de répondre
sur cet enjeu
évidemment on ne sait jamais quelle
ampleur une telle ou telle crise doit
apprendre et on sait que lorsque ça
arrive à un parti pour les autres partis
ce n'est pas une crise mais peut-être
une opportunité et pour gérer ça
également oui on va y revenir le
problème pour un chef conservateur sic
les autres ils sont dans l'opposition il
est premier ministre
aussi est ce qu un moment par ailleurs
puis vous rovers avait déjà conseillé au
prévenu je peux peut-être où on dit tant
pis l'annoncent tant pis la formule
partisane on retourne forme genre le
premier devant un rideau noir on met
tous à off parce que c'est tellement
important
oui effectivement ça peut avoir lieu on
dit bon on va tout arrêter on va se
rendre par exemple au parlement dans un
dans un endroit où finalement le premier
ministre reprend son rôle vraiment pour
une question qui touche le pays
dans ce cas aussi il n'y était pas à
tahoua donc on a décidé parce qu'il est
premier ministre assume que la décision
était vraiment évidente de procéder avec
une déclaration et répondre aux
questions en lien avec avec la photo du
petit enfant et la crise des migrants
comment au cir profits qu'elle vous y
avez fait référence de ça parce qu'on
est quand même en campagne électorale
s'est prise ces crises là peu importe
quelle qu'elle soit que celle des
interpelle parce qu'un enjeu politique
plus profond derrière l'on s'entend
comment un jamais s'éloigner de sa
comment tirer profit sans faire de la
politique partisane
moi je suis d'accord avec a dit que je
rejoins sont un délit je pense que des
gens voient qu'on essaie de tirer profit
indûment d'une crise
ça paraît dans le bas dir angoisse
apparait dans la façon qu'on s'exprime
alors il faut faire attention il faut
pas il faut avoir la vôtre antique
je pense qu'il faut dire ce qu'on pense
de l'enjeu parce que les canadiens
s'attendent à voir la position du parti
dans une banque qui nous occupe cette
semaine c'est important pour que les
chefs de partis deans mois sur cet enjeu
la voici où je me loge mais de faire
trop de capital politique soit un
hors-jeu très humain qui a touché les
gens profondément je pense que ça peut
se retourner contre soi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens tendaient des collègues
dans les salles 2
de nouvelles études et rock qui disait
mais sa frappe est tous les canadiens et
qu'ils sont profondément touché la
communauté civile s'organise et cetera
plus les politiciens mais rendue à
vendredi matin on était reparti en
campagne électorale comme si de rien
n'était est ce que vous répondez à ça
c'est pas exactement le cas ils changent
menton majeur qui a eu lieu cette
journée là et dans les jours qui ont
suivi
évidemment il ya d'autres d'autres
enjeux qui se déroule la campagne tel
rythme assez intense
il ya cette crise là mais il ya d'autres
crises aussi lorsqu'on est en campagne
tout ce qui survient est une crise
potentielle il faut juger jauger quel
est l'impact cette nouvelle loi sur les
autres campagnes et comment gérer ça
dans les circonstances la question que
beaucoup se posent monsieur alexandre il
lui a suspendu sa campagne pour une
journée je souhaite que les ministres
peuvent continuer ministre en étant
candidat en même temps il demeure
ministre alors lui sa priorité ça a été
de retourner finalement au ministère
discuter avec ces officiels et prendre
les faits
quels sont les faits aller au fond de
l'histoire sur cette femme il en
particulier et rapidement on est on a pu
rétablir les faits au sujet des demandes
ou non de réfugiés de la famille mais je
suis d'accord avec arnaud sy sall l
impact au-delà du 1er 24 heures c'est à
dire que si ta deuxième journée est
complètement
le ton est pas le bon pour ce qui s'est
passé la veille dans une crise conseil
qui va durer un bon moment
il faut changer faut pas hésiter on a
des bons plans pour les campagnes ont
donc cédé ma réflexion est ce que quand
un enjeu comme cela la crise des
réfugiés
cyrielle personnes avaient prévu le coup
ça devient un enjeu majeur comme celui
en ce moment dans la campagne électorale
que sa force les parties à retourner un
peu à la table à dessin y revoir leurs
discours l'ajuster à laval à lui c'est
la chose la plus fréquente en capital on
sait jamais ce qui va venir la journée
suivante il ya toujours quelque chose
comme ça qui arrive une annonce
économique une fermeture d'usiné à une
tragédie humaine un attentat qui s'est
donc ça c'est le lot d'une capitale et
c'est là où les world's 1
les quartiers généraux sont vraiment
importants parce que eux sont sur le
terrain nous on se promène dans l'avion
dans l'autobus avec les chefs des fois
on doit pas toujours ce qui se passe on
n'est pas à la minute près dix ans là
c'est là où les world's joue un rôle
important que voici comment ce jour
voici ce qui se passe et là nous ont
réagi au fur et à mesure il ya des
crises et prévisible comme c'était le
cas cette semaine et il a fallu ajuster
par exemple le discours de thomas
mulcair pour son investiture qui avait
lieu le soir même ils étaient mal
avisées de ne pas parler de cet art jeu
là il ya des crises prévisible aussi par
exemple le mike duffy qui devant leur
procès ça c'est prévisible on a des
munitions nous pour attaquer l'autre
partie si évidemment pour que ce soit
sur la défensive ayant d'autres exemples
gens parce que tous les participants la
recherche sur les autres parties étant
de trouver des choses pour créer un
déséquilibre dans leur campagne
mais non on va chanter dans un tout
autre ordre d'idées mais on a fait un
exercice
on est allé rencontrer des nouveaux
candidats des gens qui se présentent en
campagne électorale vous savez c'est dur
la politique pourquoi quelqu'un veut se
lancer
vous avez tous travaillé avec des
nouveaux candidats catherine j'ai
commencé avec vous parce que je suis
vous avez beaucoup travaillé avec le
candidat du québec le conseil que vous
donnez aux nouveaux venus
le premier conseil je leur donne c'est
vous avez décidé de vous lancer en
politique pour représenter vos électeurs
chez vous comme étant dans votre compte
et dans votre circonscription
alors il faut garder les électeurs
en tête il faut qu'ils parlent à leurs
électeurs
même s'ils sont dans une entrevue en
fait c'est pour que c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils sont en politique il faut
toujours les garder au centre de nos
propos au centre de nos décisions et
rester en est par rapport à ça vous
calme le conseil que vous donnez aux
nouveaux venus ont inventorié on ne ment
pas communiquer avec l'équipe i had you
afin de s'assurer au courant des
messages qu'on sait pourquoi ces gens là
sont pleins d'enthousiasmé
la maintenance est en politique vous
rentrez dans le cadre à la camisole de
force est important de ne pas inventer
les choses il ya des multitudes dangers
que peuvent souffler pendant une
campagne est candidat qui ne connaît pas
la réponse est mieux de dire je ne
connais pas les réponses pour que
d'inventer quelque chose vous mais moi
je pense que le conseil le plus concret
que je pourrai de leur candidat c'est
resté ancré dans votre compte et il
avait dans votre communauté les gens
m'ont reconnue tant ils vont voir que
vous êtes une personne qui sort sa
communauté à vous trois jours merci
d'avoir été des nôtres avec on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine